[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Sarah is
in Charlotte North Carolina hi Sarah
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi thank you so much for having me
how are you better than I deserve what's
up um so I have a two-part question um
the first part of my question is um at
what baby step do I um figure out if I
get term life insurance um I'm a single
mom to two daughters um and then the
second part of that question is if it's
worth it to me um just based on the fact
that um the other parent um my
daughter's father and I are no longer
together um and there's a history of
domestic violence so I don't necessarily
trust what will be done with life
insurance and my parents don't live in
the country um so I'm just wondering if
that's a viable option for me and what
baby step I would incorporate that too
okay it's not a baby step step it's a
now sorry it does not go in a baby step
the life insurance is a purchase out of
your budget immediately what baby step
do you put car gasoline in not a baby
step you put it in your budget you need
car gasoline to run your car you need to
take care of your children if something
happens to you and so life insurance is
an immediate purchase for you so who is
going to take care of the children if
you were to pass
away um their father um I thought he had
domestic violence issues
yeah he still has custody um due to the
fact that the domestic violence was
against me and not my children um so oh
that's encouraging it was just you I
feel so much better just me yeah that's
sarcastic oh my gosh visitation for two
months and then they deemed him fit so
in the event that I passed um
Unfortunately they would go to him and
as someone who has filed bankruptcy
twice um I don't don't trust what he
will do with that money no he doesn't
get the money he gets the
kids right okay so there is if I were to
go and speak to someone there is a way
to you would leave you would have the
beneficiary of your life insurance be a
trust and the trust would be managed by
a trustee which is um someone you select
that you trust with money and to do your
wishes and the trust would say something
like uh the children can have the income
off of the investment what do you make a
year
about
$48,000 okay so if you had a $500,000
policy and you instructed the trust to
invest that in mutual funds and it made
$50,000 a year that would replace the
income that you've created you probably
don't need that much because
hypothetically this guy's actually going
to feed these children anyway so but you
know let's just say that you did a a
48,000 okay so $4,000 a month if it made
$4,000 a month you could distribute that
to him as child support and he gets a
monthly income from to take care of the
children for the good of the children as
long as he is taking care of the
children he he you know the money goes
where the kids are so if the kids get uh
the state comes and takes them because
he commits domestic violence on them
then the money would just be you would
instruct the trust to keep the money and
build it up for when they're an
adult okay that makes sense but you
don't give him $50,000 or $500,000
correct yeah you give him monthly income
to help Feed the Children because he's
not capable of even managing his own
money so we need to send some money over
there for food what a
disaster this is not IDE this is not
this is not fun for me I don't I don't
love the idea of the kids going over
there and I really don't go love the
idea of the kids going over there with
money but I would rather them go over
there with money than without
money yeah um it's not been a fun four
years for sure yeah so like if God
forbid something were to happen I how
old are the
children they're five and
seven they're pretty young yeah
um like obviously that's my concern and
my parents don't live in the United
States um so I wouldn't be able to make
them like a executive they could they
could be they can be a trustee they can
be they don't have to be a US citizen to
be a
trustee they can be they can be in
charge of the money they could be in
charge of the money yeah you could leave
them as the
trustee okay it could be someone who
does not live in the country necessarily
that was my other concern was doesn't
matter they're not a US citizen okay
they don't have to be they're managing
money on behalf of a trust not on behalf
of themselves so you know if you go to
mama bear legal
forums.com you can get a what's called a
Family Trust form and get a will and the
will says that the money is and then buy
life insurance policy from Xander
insurance and make the beneficiary of
the life insurance meaning where the
money goes upon your death the name of
that trust the Sarah trust I'll call it
okay and it's there the the big chunk of
money whether it's $3 $400,000 is about
all it needs to be here uh goes into
that and then instruct your parents to
invest the money as the trustees and to
disperse a certain amount of money per
month to him as child
support okay and is if he no longer is
managing the children the trust no
longer sends the money to
him okay so if he were
to well I guess this is hypothetical we
don't know okay so I mean would your
parents take the children if they
could if they could they would um
obviously being from a different country
myself included um it's a bit trickier
um I've entertained the idea of moving
back home but um he would not allow it
but I think in a hypothetical where his
back was in a corner um and they were my
parents would be willing to yeah um take
them yeah so I mean I want to stipulate
a bunch of things there that as long as
they end if they end up taking care of
the children because the state takes the
kids from him at some point then they
would also be receiving the money from
this trust I want to make sure these
kids are taken care of that's all we're
doing here okay so the purpose of life
insurance is to replace the care through
money that you give your family and so
if a guy's making you know $100,000 a
year and his family is eating out of
that he needs a million dollars in life
insurance because a million
invested at making 10% would be $100,000
a year we've replace that guy if he dies
we replace the income that he's creating
we don't replace the guy but we replace
the income that he's creating that sets
him up to be able to win or sets the
kids to be a the family that's remaining
up to be able to win financially and um
not not make more money than they would
have made with him here but at least
replace what he was doing in your case
Sarah she what she was doing replace
what you are doing to care for these
children income wise because your ex is
obviously not responsible enough to send
you money over there so you're taking
care of these kids um he's not
responsible enough with money he's not
responsible enough with his own emotions
uh this is just not a good guy there's
nothing in this story that sounded
exciting to me for him oh I'm so sorry
sorry you're facing all that but Mama
Bear legal forms get your will and Trust
in place Xander Insurance get $3
$400,000 in uh life insurance it's not
very expensive it's about the cost of a
pizza and you can make that fit in your
budget especially as you get out of debt
and start to have more and more margin
so God bless you honey sorry what you
all have been through over there open
phones here at
5225 some of the most courageous people
in the world are those that are the
other side of a domestic
violence
situation and I'm an old redneck
hillbilly I don't even like the phrase
domestic violence it makes something
extremely horrible and rage inducing
sound very lame it's not lame at all it
changes family
trees it changes a it puts a curse on a
family that is
unbelievable that can only be broken by
the power of God I mean it is a it is a
nasty mess when somebody's engaging in
that stuff and sadly in the world we're
in we get to see it fairly often and it
just still just I'm I'm just an old
redneck it just pisses me off it's that
simple